If you want to hear the theory about how everything
in this movie ties back to the original train
crash in Unbreakable, then stick around to
the end of this video.
Welcome back to Things You Missed and Happy
Halloween -- this will probably be the last
episode I get to put up this October.
It went by so fast.
One thing that did not go by fast was the
wait between Unbreakable and Split.
That was a 16 year wait.
So with that in mind, waiting until January
for the third movie in the franchise, Glass,
to come out, doesn’t seem as bad.
Until then, we’ve got a second trailer,
and I’ve got some things you missed.
You may have noticed the strong color scheme
on display in Glass.
Elijah Price has a lot of purples, in his
clothes, in his shoes, in his stuff; he’s
the villain and the villains section in the
comic book store is purple, and this is also
kind of like his movie in the series and all
the the titles are purple to signify that.
Then there’s The Horde and his color is
yellow, like if you look at his comic book
pages, the indicator lights on these machines
in his room and almost all of his outfits.
Some of the rooms are either painted or lit
to match these colors and there is line suggesting
that Elijah and the Horde could team up,
“That sounds like the bad guys teaming up.”
...which may be the reason this room is striped
in yellow and purple.
David Dunn is green, the color of his iconic
rain poncho from the first movie until now,
and the color of his outfit at the mental
institution matches that, and the heroes section
of the comic book store is green as well.
The respective characters’ colors are made
very obvious in the poster, though I do hope
we get another poster at some point with the
cracked glass on it to match up with the Split
and Unbreakable posters that fit together
when laid out, side by side.
You can also see each of their colors represented
in different rooms on the security monitors
if you pause right here.
You may be wondering why there is so much
focus on these colors.
I recommend you go pay attention to the movies.
Peace.
No, OK fine.
I think the colors are there to represent
David’s innate ability to sense evil.
He has this sense, A Sixth Sense if you will.
OK I really have to stop trying to put jokes
in my videos.
In the first movie, we see that if David touches
someone, he can see the bad things that they’ve
done and he can track bad people in a crowd
because their color will stand out to him
and become much more saturated.
So I think purple and yellow are their villain
colors, as seen by David.
Once David and The Horde are captured and
put into the institution, the woman studying
them, her name’s Dr. Staple, has individual
methods for keeping them all in check.
For Elijah, they keep him sedated, because
apparently he’s become such a good manipulator,
they can’t even handle him if he’s fully
awake.
"He's too smart for them."
David’s room is filled with these pipes
and nozzles because his weakness is water,
so they can give him a spray whenever he becomes
unruly.
This would also be an effective room for scientists
to study the aliens from Signs, don’t you
think?
The method that they used to keep The Horde
under control is pretty much explained verbatim
in the trailer.
“The light will force a different identity
to take over.”
“Por favor, senor.”
“I want my headphones back.”
“Step away from the controls now little
darling.”
“Can’t beat The Beast!”
When I did the video talking about the first
Glass trailer, I
wondered why Dr. Staple didn’t have The
Horde chained down like David Dunn.
In this trailer, you can see that the flashing
lights are set up behind her so she can change
him to a different personality if things get
dicey.
The fact that these are the weaknesses is
very interesting to me, and here’s why.
Think back to Unbreakable.
One of the most iconic scenes in that movie,
heck, one of the most iconic scenes in cinema,
is the scene where he rescues the kidnapped
kids in the rain, almost drowning in the pool
as he does so.
That’s an epic scene, but imagine what the
final showdown could be like in Glass.
The fight breaks through a glass window into
a thunderstorm.
David is dramatically weakened by the water,
but the intermittent flashes of lightning
cause the Horde to be constantly changing
personalities, throwing him into complete
disarray.
So it will come down to Elijah to think of
some clever solution.
When I did the Things You Missed on the first
Glass trailer, I broke down this entire comic
that appears on screen and I talked about
how this character could represent either
The Horde or David, because of his desire
to protect people.
In this trailer we get a glimpse at another
panel of this comic.
It says: “I vowed to protect everyone from
those of us given these cruel gifts.”
That line suggests that this is more likely
representative of David.
"Why is it do you think that of all the professions
in the world, you chose protection?"
However, I wouldn’t also rule out the possibility
that this is a sign that The Beast will change
sides, and realize that he wants to be a good
guy.
Also, I think they’ve already learned their
lesson about The Beast’s ability to bend
bars, because it looks like in his room, he’s
got bricks for windows.
Next there’s a scene in which Elijah sneaks
into the record room and accesses The Horde’s
medical file.
Let’s pause on that and take a closer look.
You’ll notice some of the names of the identities
familiar to us from Split, such as Rakel,
Luke, Polly, Bernice and of course, The Beast.
We know this because each identity has a file
on the computer in Split.
However, there are some new names here, like
this name ending in “--elida” and this
name ending in the letters “MA”.
So this could be evidence that there are still
new personalities emerging within The Horde,
just as The Beast emerged as a 24th personality
back in Split.
Speaking of The Beast, the first time Kevin’s
body transformed into The Beast was at a train
station in Split.
The backstory is glossed over and we find
out in that movie that Kevin’s dad left
on a train when he was a child and never came
back -- leading some to believe that this
emotional damage caused the identity disorder,
and some to theorize that the train he left
on was Eastrail 177, the train that crashed
and left David Dunn as the only survivor.
I bring this all up because the new trailer
reveals a scene taking place in what appears
to be a hobo camp inside of a subway station
and The Beast is the one who exploring it.
And probably scaring the hobos so bad.
I mean, could you imagine hiding in an abandoned
tunnel and all the sudden this approaches
you?
There is one other possible callback hidden
in this trailer, and that is when Elijah Price
is addressing David at the microphone.
“David.
I found someone who will require your full
potential."
This monologue is very reminiscent of the
voicemails Elijah leaves on David’s answering
machine in Unbreakable, where he tries to
encourage him to embrace his super-hero side.
"David?
It's Elijah.
It was so obvious.
It was this one issue that brought it back
for me.
This group, the coalition of evil tried to
ascertain the weakness of every superhero,
because they all have one."
Alright, I do a have a few more Things You
Missed, but not a whole lot to say about them.
The first is in this shot, and while we’re
focused on Elijah, some dude gets wrecked
by The Beast in the background -- that’s
a super interesting choice to have the action
play out as a barely noticeable background
detail, so I’m interested to see how that
plays out in the actual movie.
Then in this shot, I noticed David Dunn’s
son Joseph holding his arm as if he’s injured.
Joseph always believed that his Dad was a
superhero, and there are a few instances where
he puts his dad in dangerous situations to
try to prove it.
I have to wonder if he starts to believe he
has inherited these same powers, and that’s
how he gets himself hurt, or if one of the
bad guys targets him to try to rattle David.
Towards the end of the trailer, Elijah can
be spotted wearing this necklace with the
initials MG.
I'm assuming that stands for Mr. Glass, and
if that's true then it seems like Elijah's
really playing in to his super villain persona.
Then we've got a shot of Casey Cooke from
Split getting off of this bus, and this is
actually the same bus that David gets off
in his neighborhood in Unbreakable.
Now, it's hard to say if that's an actual
reference to Unbreakable or if this is just
a common bus-line in Philadelphia, so if any
of you guys are from Philly, feel free to
let me know in the comments.
So I’ve got several videos in the pipeline
right now.
As I mentioned this is probably the last of
the October uploads.
I know I had also expressed interest in doing
an episode on the Happy Death Day 2U trailer.
That’s because I thought it was out already
-- but they haven’t actually put it online
yet, despite the fact that it is playing in
front of Halloween in theaters right now.
I would like to wait for that to come out
on YouTube before I do the Things You Missed
episode.
And I know there has been a lot Things You
Missed lately, and there is a reason for that.
A lot of you have been asking where the next
Al Dente Creepypasta is, for those of you
who don’t know, that’s my scary story
narration series, I’ve got some new episodes
planned, so that should be back soon as well.
And I have decided to do a little marathon
leading up to the release of Glass, I’ll
be doing Things You Missed on Unbreakable
and Split, so if you are a fan of this thriller-horror
series, which I’m imagining you are if you’ve
made it this far in the video, then remember
to subscribe to CZsWorld for new horrors every
week, ring that deathbell for notifications
and I’ll see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.